no es un muro de paz como el presidente
de mexico lo llamo es una de las tantas
divisiones que las autoridades
instalaron para evitar el paso de los
manifestantes en ciudad de mexico el día
internacional de la mujer en el país de
américa latina que más casos de
feminicidio registra se celebró con ir a
la misma que se siente al saber que
cerca de 1000 mujeres fueron asesinadas
en 2020 solamente es el hecho de que se
tome una precaución en cuanto a escuchar
lo que se pide y algo que se pide es una
seguridad mayor para que nosotros
podamos ir caminando para que podamos ir
con nuestra vida como cualquier otra
persona en bolivia numerosos colectivos
feministas marcharon el país andino
registra en lo que va del año 300 51
casos de violaciones a mujeres y 342 de
abuso sexual
y una mujer más adinerada está
que nosotros nos duele lo que nos hacen
que nos peguen que nos hacen que nos
violen y que el estado no haga nada
y qué pasa los jueces liberen a los
violentos porque te meterán para
constitucional
y por mis hijas mi madre por mi abuela
en venezuela a pesar de que el
presidente nicolás maduro prohibió las
concentraciones varios grupos opositores
y de feministas organizaron pequeñas
manifestaciones
jóvenes en el país nos levantamos
le decimos al pueblo venezolano si hay
futuro venezuela pero hay que pelearlo
en brasil decenas de personas marcharon
con cruces negras para recordar los 649
feminicidios que hubo durante el primer
semestre de 2020 y en argentina tras la
legalización del aborto a finales de
2020 los movimientos feministas
aprovecharon la celebración
internacional para pedir equidad
salarial y más protección ante una tasa
de elevada de feminicidios a pesar de
las medidas de confinamiento por la
pandemia de kobe 19 cada 30 horas una
mujer es asesinada en argentina
aproximadamente